she has sexual opportunity because she's
hot but most women are not as hot as her
and the other side of divorce is
actually going to be pretty miserable
um most women are in debt they don't
have money so this idea that oh you can
just come out of divorce with a little
money yeah you do and let's be honest
what do we see with female pop stars a
lot of them piss away their money they
don't even keep it you know I I've
spoken to guys like that are in the
music industry like I know someone that
has produced for a lot of like top
artists right and he told me that a lot
of these chicks just you know they get
famous they make their money and they
end up broke at 70. and with roommates
you know and that's the future the the
future of tomorrow